hundreds of people from around the world
came to coffee abbien huckster to pay
their respects to onion eating us this
was her home town where she returned to
unwind after tough assignments in war
zones her friends and colleagues talked
about her courage integrity and cheerful
demeanor even in the face of danger
Seligman gurgling Glee you would sent
her an email and asked where she was at
the moment during the second Iraq war
she would write back I'm in Iraq the
weather is fine it's raining bombs love
Anya in piarc bumpin veteran here cause
Anya the horrors of war that an you
experienced with soldiers from various
countries never robbed her of her
feminine authenticity or of her courage
her first assignment to a combat zone
was in Yugoslavia in 1992 then she went
on to the world's other trouble spots
the Middle East Libya Iraq Afghanistan
and Pakistan she was injured a number of
times she said she was often afraid but
probably less so than someone who wasn't
familiar with a situation on the ground
she never liked the label of war
photographer she was more interested in
the impact of war on people Legion House
was murdered last week in Afghanistan's
Khost province she was with veteran AP
reporter kathy gannon who was wounded in
the attack